we mourn every uh loss of life that
we've had throughout the coronavirus
epidemic and uh what i would say to
and and our sympathies with obviously
with the families of the of the breed
what i what i would say uh to to them is
that we really owe it to them
to continue our work in driving the
virus
down and clearly this country has had
a massive success now in reducing the
numbers of those tragic
deaths and we've got it
at the moment under some measure of
control the numbers of deaths are well
well done
but i have to tell you that we're
looking at
a resurgence of the virus in some other
european countries you can see what's
been happening in the united states
and so it is absolutely vital as a
country
that we continue to keep our focus
and our discipline and that we don't
delude ourselves
that somehow we're out of the woods or
that this is all over because it isn't
all over and the most important thing we
can do
to stop a second wave a really damaging
second wave is which would have real
real consequences not just
medical but also for the economy
is everybody continue to observe
the social distancing guidelines to wash
your hands
to wear a mask on public transport or in
shops
and the most important thing we need to
do
is get a test if you have
symptoms
that you should isolate for ten days not
seven days this is at the same time on
the first of august that some
national restrictions are going to be
further eased
confusion rains doesn't it people are
confused by what the national government
is telling them to do that's
what you've left people with at this
point at the end of july isn't it let's
be
clear there's only one way of
controlling the
coronavirus at present uh obviously
we're
making great progress with uh with drugs
like dexter methazone rem deserve
uh where we're able to to deal with in
ways we weren't able to do
in early march but broadly speaking the
only way to control
coronavirus is if everybody collectively
obeys the social distancing rules and
works together
to drive the virus down so that's why i
make this
this point that i that i do we've done a
huge amount
together we've we've really reduced the
incidence of the virus
and we've got the number of deaths down
but it can come up
again and we've seen what's happening in
other european countries so what i'm
saying to
to people is don't lose focus
don't lose discipline continue to
observe
those guidelines and if you have
symptoms
get a test uh two regional questions to
finish with prime minister and tourism
is a vital
part of the north yorkshire economy to
go back to this issue of confusing
people should people
stay at home this summer or should they
have a staycation because to reiterate
again
you know you're sending mixed messages
to people aren't you well i think we're
very very keen to support uh the
fantastic tourism
industry here in north yorkshire and the
rest of the and the rest of the country
and uh we've done all sorts of things uh
to back it up
uh all sorts of investments we've made
in uh in tourism supporting
the tourist industry throughout the the
country uh with the
the chronovirus packages of one kind or
another 160 billion pounds worth
but what i really would say to people is
that uh you know it looks a bit wet now
but it's fantastic weather generally
uh here in in north yorkshire there are
wonderful
attractions uh in in north yorkshire and
across
the country and i am not going to
discourage anybody
from having a staycation uh this is a
totally beautiful
country throughout the united kingdom
there are there are fantastic amenities
resorts beaches destinations of all
kinds
and i thoroughly thoroughly recommend
them final local question prime minister
um in terms of local lockdowns bradford
council does have some additional
restrictions on people in that city at
the moment it does
they're saying that um as the further
restrictions nationally are eased on the
first of august
that the government is moving too
quickly and too fast and that as a
result
cases in bradford but in places like
oldham will go up what do you say to the
people of bradford
well what i say to everywhere that is
seeing
an increase in the in the in the virus
and i'm afraid there are about
uh you know between 10 and 30 places
that you where you are seeing
uh it bubbling up a little bit
i say to them i know it's tough i know
that it's requiring
a lot of patience to to get through
through this we will
continue to support it i think the
country as a whole understands
that the best way to to deal with this
is if we have tough
local lockdowns tough tough swift and
and decisive local lockdowns to keep it
and get it under control
in the in those towns it's principally
in those in those towns
and i pay tribute to the efforts of
local people in
many many places from uh from kirklees
to ashford
uh across the country it's going down
now in leicester uh they're making a
huge effort
and i thank them uh for what they're
doing but that is the way to deal with
it we need
uh to bring it under control locally to
protect
uh the whole of the uk you feel your
message is clear to people
i do thank you thank you very much